[Music]
Kameron recently spent time with the
cast in Hawaii in a helicopter no less
he said it was dynamite my giving him so
it was only right that the a-list
treatment continued back on land
got the carpet again yeah I know I'm
gonna put these carpets in our contracts
for the next community from now on
that's how I want to arrive to like arts
or my interviews that's pretty ideal
it's not hail from here action if you
think this locale was spectacular what
must it have been like for Bryce's 11
and 6 year olds and Chris's
five-year-old ridiculous tragic movies
half a million dollar puppets just
mind-blowing
it's like chucky cheese on Stuart
I mean it's it's especially meaningful
because I grew up on movie set so you
know getting getting to have my kids
here it's incredible what he's not
combating dinosaurs Chris is out there
fighting the heat so sweaty all day
that's why I wear the deep V undershirt
which I should be wearing right now like
I'm really failing big time it's an
essential out here for me if I don't
have it then you see these nice little
big smiles it's so crazy that you asked
me happy I actually have no sense of
smell I actually have no sense of snuff
oh really
nope that's a that's that's why we're
such a good team well we know Chris
loves food this is seaweed his hilarious
Instagram posts which my snack
originated from the Jurassic world set
that looks gross but it's not I guess it
like clear him coming up with what's my
snack that's right what is my snack if
I'm making it myself Mike I know my
snack 14 eggs season two's coming get
ready lots of twists and turns
wait do you say 14 eggs 14 eggs Wow by
the way tonight is the big premiere in
Hollywood Cameron will be there to bring
you all the action for tomorrow right
back here on the sack
[Applause]
you